can we start off um
with the film because
it's a film about
the sexuality of middle aged women
in many ways and about compassion too
but
and you've been in the business for a
long long time do you think a script
like this could have been would have
been even written five or ten years ago
maybe five years ago but 10 years ago
probably not actually i think it's a
very good question because um even
though things have been changing and
there are more interesting things for
women don't forget you know five years
ago mindy kaling wrote
late night which is about a
female talk show host which has never
been seen on screen before never been
thought about which is actually when you
think about it completely mad
completely mad
why isn't there
a female talk show host that's not
what because women can't talk um
no does not compute everybody it's just
crazy anyway they have don't have
interesting personalities and are fun
i so
um but what's sort of original about it
is
is the encounter itself and the fact
that it's about
so many things it is about female
sexuality of course but it's about
sexual pleasure and shame across the
board
and about you know the possible kind of
sanctity of sex work as well
for 31 years my husband would climb on
top do the business roll off put his
pajamas on and go back to sleep
i've never had an orgasm
and yes in fact if we do this
[Music]
you will only be the second man i have
ever had sex with
oh god no nancy this is crazy it's
terrible it's wrong nancy yes let's go
to bed okay
it really does cover so much it doesn't
you're right about the middle age thing
you know i really enjoyed it because i
thought it spoke to an audience that
sometimes isn't spoken to or off
and um it seemed to me as well it was
sort of correct and an imbalance in that
the cinema is often besotted with sort
of young women and treating them as
sexual beings and a man sexy at any age
and then women
as they get older they sort of disappear
like sexually they disappear well it
would be a pretty big thing to try and
counteract with one acting role in a
film um so yeah i try not to think about
the sort of global implications of my
work while i'm acting something i'm just
trying to make it as truthful as
possible whether it does
have that effect it would be lovely but
um i don't think about it in those
universal terms it's interesting to talk
about it afterwards but what i was
was drawn to was
this woman who'd um
really ticked all the boxes i think this
is the interesting thing that there are
lots of shapes that we invited to get
into and i think i mean dazzle say you
know men as well this is what you should
be women in particular because they
don't have as much freedom like it or
not everyone says oh no we've done all
that no we haven't so
accept that because we haven't done it
yet you know women are not as free as
men to do what they want they're simply
not and so nancy's um
admissions about the
limitations of her life and the
limitations of what she's experienced
are very painful did you feel sorry for
nancy i mean meeting when you meet your
fourth meeting she says you're the only
adventurer i've ever had the only
freedom and then in the fast meeting you
know she says she tells you i've never
had an orgasm i've i've never had all
sets did you both
when you read the switch did you think
poor nancy
did you think poor nancy i i'm not
particularly because i think we come
from a similar place where i felt i i
thought it was incredible that she
was making this choice for herself that
she was taking this autonomy yeah to go
and seek this experience you know kind
of at her age as well and and at the
experience that she's been given prior
to this moment so
i never felt
um poor nancy i i thought wow the kind
of scope of the experience that she's
going through and and the vulnerability
that she's walking through to get there
yeah i thought was quite incredible to
see so you know i think i i never tried
to have an emotional take on where they
were coming from i just was fascinated
by the difference in their walks of life
and what they were both going through i
do feel
the tragedy of her
you know get at 16 sort of nearly having
access to her sexuality and then it
being something taken away and then she
goes and does array levels and goes to
teacher training and becomes a teacher
and gets married and does all the things
right and does everything right does
everything right
um and never ever
returns or never continues that journey
because as she says you know she was
pretty much living in the 50s but to be
honest with you beth i don't think that
that female pleasure
is at the top of anybody's
to-do kind of list
i've never done anything interesting or
remarkable in my life
this is it i see my friends shriveling
up over the years
i'm sorry
nancy everyone needs something different
i don't judge my
clients unless they're totally ourselves
it also seemed to me
that
for nancy she grew up in a world as you
said where female pleasure was not
something discussed in fact if anything
female sexuality was almost a taboo
do you think that'll be an
intergenerational difference where
younger women might watch this film and
go oh my god my poor mother aunt grandma
is that what they had to put up with and
they won't relate to it because they're
like that's not how we live now we're
empowered sexually about we i've talked
to lots of young women about this and
many well quite a few of them said to me
i didn't even know about masturbation
until i was in my twenties
you know we think
that this revolution has occurred
because young women 22 23 years old that
surprises me actually well
here we are we're here to be surprised
aren't we because we live in london and
we've lived in you know this sort of
rather metropolitan cosmopolitan world
where people have access to all sorts of
things and read cosmopolitan which sort
of suggests that if you haven't had an
orgasm in the last 15 minutes you're not
truly alive you know which is a form of
i think it's kind of bullying you know
if you're not emerging
fantastic yeah you're right
just sort of yes
just having spontaneous orgasms
at westminster you know because that's
like you're just
in it and there you know as if it's an
easy thing to achieve
but i think i i
i
i think we
we're very dishonest
about sex and i think we're often very
dishonest about how much
we're actually enjoying it to be honest
well actually that's one thing i really
liked film was about it kind of picked
up on the sort of awkwardness and
weirdness of sex sometimes as well
didn't it
between the two characters
i just want to ask someone about it
there was a there's there's a bit of a a
dark moment i thought in the film
when nancy gets quite upset
with leo because he's sort of saying
well you might want more sessions and
it's really because he's saying you
might you actually just need to talk to
me and then she says i'm paying you for
a service i don't have my just get on
with it and it kind of
it it makes it really transaction
because you forget that this is a
transaction
um
there's a danger in the film could you
imagine if you did the exact same film
but the genders of the protagonists were
reversed it becomes more sinister so
it's becomes
make this film and reverse the gender
you couldn't you simply couldn't make it
because the playing field is not level
it
it just wouldn't make any sense
there's nothing to explore there or
there's other things to explore but they
would be very very different i just want
to ask you one other thing on that
ageism it's still a prejudice that sort
of seems permissible in society and for
older women they often suffer a sort of
double prejudice because you're too old
for
roles you're too old to have sex you're
too old to even be seen anymore is that
something you feel strongly about or as
you get older do you feel it's changing
well i'm
i've been very lucky because young women
like katie and mindy have written things
for me that are completely not haven't
been seen before which says two things
first of all i don't feel invisible
and second of all there's
change
because young women don't just want to
write films about young women they want
to write films about all female
experience
and also because katie was interested in
writing something about a young man
and young men's experience which is i
think
quite hard yeah i think it's interesting
about the i think katie did a really
good job you know there's something
interesting about leo in the context
that he is in a professional environment
so we don't really get to see much of
his inner life but i think it's it's i'm
really grateful katie did know that he
is also going through his own journey
with regards to sexuality with regards
to kind of um body image at some point
as well but i think
that's the reason why he's able to be
here and lay this foundation because i
think he's gone through his own
experience so i think i hope even though
it's not as as fleshed out i think
there is an element there where you know
the that young men will also go through
their own version i think that's what is
universal about this is that we do have
to look at that journey for ourselves
daryl when you were born emma was
already a major thing right she's a
major star was it weird to be cast in a
romantic relationship
when you were born as you were coming
out yeah
yeah so what the oscars are usually in
january right yes that's right so i was
born in january 93. that was the year
you won yourself that's right that's
right and then you're in a romantic
relationship how was that incredible
it's not incredible i think that's i
mean that's that's amazing that this job
that we do that you can really just be
completely different you can really
share environments like this it's so
funny that's amazing isn't it actually i
haven't thought about it like that yeah
generationally you asked beth earlier
which is which is very interesting i
think that
there's abs it's absolutely
true that my mother's generation
um had a completely different entry into
sort of sexual life to my generation and
you're younger than me but you know 60s
70s i was born in 59 and then my
daughter's generation those three
generations of women it'd be very
interesting to do something about yeah
the three but it's got better for your
daughter
i hope so i mean i think some things
have
i think some things are worse when i
hear stories in
schools about boys and what they expect
from girls and
oh well
i mean that the easy access to porn you
know if you talk to young people about
their sexual knowledge and what they
expect and what they think sex is it can
be very disturbing indeed and i think
can interfere with their sexual
development because it's all been taken
away industrialized and fed back to them
in a sort of completely
kind of
unindigestible form
you know um so so i think that there are
uh pressures
outside i also think that the sexual
revolution is a very complex
um
issue it's not like we had that and then
everything was better and now young
people it's all better it's never like
that in human experience we we take a
step forward and then we tie ourselves
into weird knots because the fact of the
matter is we have no respect at all for
our sexual desires we ridicule them
we've we we make them the butt of our
jokes we we we don't respect
what
our desires are and we find when they're
odd which they often are we find them
shameful and ridiculous i just wanted to
ask you finally there's a major refugee
crisis in europe you've spoken about
refugee causes your own adopted son i
think was it was a refugee
do you think we're doing enough at the
moment
for refugees
and for ukraine no
but i mean you know refugees across the
board the real problem is our sort of
referral mechanisms are a mess and the
rwanda scheme is
um
sort of eye-wateringly mad and um
callous
you know we're exhibiting a callousness
callousness in government that i don't
think reflects the soul of this country
and the nature of the people in this
country i really don't
um i understand that that
uh
you know a lot of refugees will be
thinking well it's all you know all the
ukrainians are white and this kind of
welcome wasn't given to syrian refugees
when the same sort of thing was
happening in aleppo and all that and i
understand that too but at the same time
there's been a huge compassionate
opening of of british people
people in this country have all wanted
to help so so much and been um
really severely uh prevented from doing
so by government mechanisms and
all sorts of
internal difficulties with things like
bank accounts and
not our civil society not somehow being
helped to rise to the occasion i mean
this is a very very complex issue but
the movement of peoples not only due to
war but due to climate change is going
to be the most one of the biggest issues
of our time and certainly of the 21st
century and we better start getting our
minds around how people need to move and
we'll have we will have to accept that
we can't become fortresses we can't put
up walls anymore it's not realistic
we've run out of time but maybe one day
we could do another interview together
you know we'll do more political ones
yeah well look thank you so much thanks
for thanks for uh spending some time
talking to me and congratulations on the
film
which i'm going to force everyone i know
to watch that's brilliant i like the
word force yeah i think that's good
i mean i'm now an empowered middle-aged
woman and i'm gonna force everyone